اهلا بكم نفت مصادر مقربه من رئيس الوزراء
الفلسطيني سلام فياض ان يكون تقدم
باستقالته بسبب خلافه مع الرئيس محمود
عباس وكانت مصادر فلسطينيه اكدت ان
استقاله فياض جاءت بعد وصول خلافاته مع
العباس الى طريق المسدود نتوقف بعد الخبر
لنناقشه من زاويتين
ما اسباب استقاله فياض التي بقيت في دائره
التكهنات رغم تقديمها قبل اكثر من اسبوع
تتعل
ق ما هي المحددات التي يبث على اساسها في
مصير هذه الاستقاله
ليست المره الاولى التي يقدم فيها رئيس
الوزراء الفلسطيني سلام فياض استقالته الى
الرئيس محمود عباس فعل ذلك عام 2011 ثم
جدد مرتين جددها مرتين بعد ذلك في اطار
متطلبات المصالحه الفلسطينيه ورغم ان
مقربين من فياض اصروا على ان استقالته
الاخيره تاتي في نفس الاطار الا ان ما
تسرب من انباء يؤكد ان وراءها خلافات
طويله مع الرئيس عباس غبتها ضغوط فتحويه
على مستوى النعال ترى في فياض عبء ان
الاوان التحلل منه او ربما تاخر
ليس جديدا ان تتردد انباء استقاله رئيس
الوزراء الفلسطيني سلام فياض فقد سبق ان
تردد ذلك مرارا منذ الحديث عن المصالحه
الفلسطينيه واعلان الدوحه الذي نص على
تشكيل حكومه وحده وطنيه برئاسه الرئيس
محمود عباس ويضع مكتب فياض الاستقلال
الراهنه ضمن ذات السياق لكن اسئله كثيره
تطرح على الساحه هل الامور فعلا كذلك ام
ان الاستقاله تاتي كما تردد على خلفيه
خلافات متصاعده بين الحكومه والسلطه
انفجرت بقبول الفياض قبل اسابيع استقاله
وزير الماليه دون الرجوع للرئيس مهما كانت
الاسباب فان الرئيس الفلسطيني تعرض لضغوط
غربيه تحثه على عدم البت في الاستقاله
وتاجيل ذلك شهرين على الاقل حتى تظاهر
نتائج الجهود الامريكيه لاحياء عمليه
السلام حسب ما افادت مصادر مقربه من عباس
ربما يحظى رئيس الوزراء الفلسطيني باعجاب
الغرب لكنه لم ينجح في بناء قاعده قويه
داخل فلسطين وظل عرضه للهجوم من حركه حماس
التي تسيطر على قطاع غزه ومن حركه الفتح
بالضفه الغربيه وايضا من شعب الضفه الذي
طالما استفزته السياسات الحكومه
الاقتصاديه
وتتحدث الانباء عن صراع خفي بين فياض وفتح
التي ظلت تنتقد السياسات حكومته بشده ربما
براي دوائر مختلفه لان فتح تريد حصتها في
السلطه بالضفه اسوه بحماس المنفرده بغزه
وغضب كثير من عناصر الفتح اثناء احتياجات
الشعبيه التي حملتهم مسؤوليه السياسات
حكومه فياض وكثيرا ما تحدثت عناصر من فتح
عن ضغوط تمارسها الحكومه على كوادر الحركه
بغزه الذين تدفع السلطه الفلسطينيه
رواتبهم منذ المفاصل بين فتح وحماس عام
2006 وحسب ما يرشح من مصادر الفتح فان
كثيرا من قياديها يرحبون في ظل الظروف
الراهنه بحكومه تعبر عنهم ويتسنى للشعب
والمجتمع الدولي محاسبتهم على سياساتها
وان لم يعلن ذلك
معنى في هذه الحلقه من رام الله محمد رغما
الصحفي والمحلل السياسي
وخليل شاهين مدير البحوث في مركز مسارات
لابحاث السياسات والدراسات الاستراتيجيه
اهلا بضيفينا لو بدانا بالسيد دراغمه هل
اتضحت الصوره الان لماذا استقال السيد
سلام فياض
من الواضح ان الدكتور سلام فياض قد استقال
قدم استقالته وقد قبلت الاستقاله من قبل
الرئيس محمود عباس التاجيل لان هنالك
وسطات وهنالك ضغوط على الرجلين حتى يعني
يعدلاع عن خلافاتهما السبب الحقيقي وراء
الاستقاره التي فجرها هو الخلاف حول وزير
الماليه وزير المال استقال رئيس الحكومه
قبل استقالته الرئيس رفضها وهنا حدث نزاع
على الصلاحيات من هو صاحب الصلاحيات في
الحكومه الرئيس ام رئيس الحكومه السبب
الثاني غير المباشر هي الحمله الطويله
التي تخوضها حركه فتح او بعض مراكز القوه
في حركه فتح ضد سلام فياض هذه الحمله
فياض راى فيها هجوما على شخصه واساءه
شخصيه له وكان يناقش طوال الوقت انه يمثل
نظاما سياسيا يجب ان ادعمه اما ان يكون
رئيس وزراء لنظام سياسي لا يدعموه فمن
الافضل له ان يذهب الى البيت
سيد خليل شاهين هل هل هذا التبرير الذي
تفضل به الان سيد دراغمه وهذا الشرح من ان
القضيه هي قضيه صلاحيات وقضيه ضغوط
متواصله من فتح هل هذا ما اجمع عليه الكل
تقريبا الان فيما يتعلق باسباب استقاله
السيد فياض
نعم الى حد ما انا اتفق مع السيد دراغمه
ولكن انا ارى ان هذه مظاهر او نتائج
الازمه الاكثر عمقا القائمه حاليا ماذا
يعني الخلاف حول منصب وزير الماليه انه
يعني صراع على المال من يملك المال ويتحكم
بيستطيع ان يملك مزيدا من النفود وهذا
الامر يجب ان يضاف ايضا الى اعتقاد السيد
فياض بانه يجري تحجيمه من خلال عدم
مسؤوليته المباشره انجاز التعبير او سلطته
المباشره حول حقائب على حقائب سياديه
رئيسيه مثل الخارجيه والاوقاف واضافه الى
موضوع الامن الذي لم يعد له سلطه واضحه
عليه كما كان الحال قبل فتره زمنيه بمعنى
اخر نحن نشرب ايضا صراعا على المواقع
القوه والنفوذ في السلطه الفلسطينيه له
علاقه على الاقل من وجهه نظر حركه فتح
وكذلك من وجهه نظافه النظر الاطراف
الخارجيه التي تمارس الضغط بالمرحله
القادمه انجاز التعبير لا سيما ان الرئيس
عباس يكرر باستمرار انه لا يرغب بالترشح
للرئاسه لولايه جديده في كل الاحوال انا
اعتقد ان الجوانب الاخرى يجب ان لا تغفل
وهي مسؤوليه دكتور فياض عن الازمه
الاقتصاديه الاجتماعيه بفعل الخطه التي
اقرها وهي مسؤوليه جزئيه انجاز التعبير
فالحكومه في نهايه المطاف هي حكومه السيد
الرئيس وعليه ايضا ان يتحمل مسؤوليه تجاه
هذه الحكومه خصوصا انه يردد باستمرار ان
الحكومه هي الحكومته وهي العباره التي
طالما سمعناها في الحوارات ما بين حركتي
حماس وفتح عفوا اذا كانت اذا كانت المساله
هي مساله صلاحيات ومساله مال هنا اريد ان
اسال سيد دراهمه هل هل هل يشبه المشهد ولو
في خطوط العريضه ما جرى في فتره من
الفترات بين الرئيس الراحل ياسر عرفات
ومحمود عباس عندما كان رئيسا للوزراء
هي تماما هي الصوره تتكرر قبل عشر سنوات
الذين حملوا استقاله الرئيس ابو مازن في
حينه الى الرئيس ياسر عرفات هم الذين
حملوا استقاله فياض الان الى الرئيس ابو
مازن وحول ذات الموضوع هي نزاع على
الصلاحيات وليس على السياسات لا يوجد خلاف
في السياسات الماليه السياسات الاقتصاديه
الموازنه
الحكومه تحضر هذه السياسات والرئيس يقرها
لا خلاف على السياسات على الاطلاق حتى
الرياضه لا يوجد خلاف عليها الخلاف هو على
الصلاحيات
والسبب الحقيقي يبدو لي ان
الركود الذي تعيشه الحياه السياسيه
الفلسطينيه بعد الانقسام قبل حوالي منذ
العام 2007 الى الان
لا يوجد انتخابات لا يوجد مجلس تشريعي
يراقب لا يوجد
هنالك تقديم كشف الى الناخب الى الجمهور
نشا نوع من الركود وفي حالات الركود ينشا
صراع على السلطه لان المسؤول في موقعه
يتحول الى ملك الرئيس هو ملك رئيس الوزراء
هو ملك رئيس المجلس التشريعي هو ملك لا
يوجد اي تغيير في الحياه السياسيه
الفلسطينيه واصحاب المناصب هنا يتصارعون
يتنازعون الصلاحيات وبالتالي تنشا بينهم
هذا النوع من الخلافات التي تصل الى طرق
مسدوده ولكن سيد رغم الاشاره الاشاره الى
ما حصل نعم عفوا الاشاره الى ان هذا ملك
وهذا ملك في حين ان الملك اصلا غير موجود
وهنا اعود للسيد شاهين اشارته للمال وانه
صراع على المال هل هو صراع على المال ام
صراع على عدم وجود المال في النهايه لانه
في الحقيقه السلطه الفلسطينيه تعيش ازمه
ماليه خانقه منذ اشهر ليست خافيه وهنا
سؤال للسيد شاهين
هذا السؤال جيد وهو سؤال الجوهري عندما لا
يوجد مال بل ولا توجد سلطه فعليه فعلى
ماذا يدور الصراع سواء في اطار السلطه في
الضفه الغربيه او بين السلطتين القائمتين
في الضفه الغربيه وقطاع غزه انا اعتقد ان
المشكله الامر فيما يتعلق ببرنامج الدكتور
فياض هو انه راهن على امكانيه تحقيق
برنامج عنوانه كان بناء المؤسسات وانهاء
الاحتلال لمده عامين انتهى العامين وظيفه
عام اخر دون ان يخرج فياض الى الراي العام
الفلسطيني ليقول انه فشل في هذا البرنامج
وانه كان
رهانا على التدخل الخارجي الان امتد هذا
الخلاف من المال الى السياسه انا اعتقد ان
هناك خلاف حقيقي في مجال السياسه فرئيس
الوزراء ليس منسجما مع السياسه التي
يطبقها الرئيس هو عارض التوجه نحو المجلس
الامن للحصول على العضويه الكامله كمعارضه
التوجه نحو الجمعيه العامله للحصول على
عضويه الدوله المراقبه وبالتاكيد اعتقد
انه يعارض ايضا النتائج يمكن ان تترتب على
ذلك اي الذهاب الى مواجهه دبلوماسيه
للحصول على العضويه الكامله في منظمات
ووكالات الامم المتحده
الخلافه على هذا اذا كان الخلاف سيد شاهين
عفوا اذا كان الخلافه على هذا القدر من
الخطوره برايك لماذا بالطبع الرئيس ياسر
عرفات والدوائر عفوا الرئيس محمود عباس
والدوائر المحيطه به لم تتحدث
الدوائر المقربه من الدكتور سلام فياض
تحاول ان تهون من الموضوع وتتحدث بان في
النهايه استقالته هي للتمهيد
للساحه المجال للرئيس ابو مازن حتى يشكل
حكومه الوحده الوطنيه التي يراسها هو
لا علاقه لذلك على
بموضوع المصالحه على الاطلاق دعنا نتذكر
هنا ان الرئيس كان قد اصدر على تسميه فياض
رئيسا لاي حكومه التوافق وطني يجري
تشكيلها بالمناسبه انا يعني اعتقد ان حركه
حماس في المرحله الراهنه يمكن ان توافق
على شخصيه مستقله لرئاسه الحكومه غير
الرئيس عباس بما في ذلك الدكتور سلام فياض
اي ان هذه العقبه تم تنزيلها من فتره هناك
مشكله ان فياض يريد البقاء في منصبه لانه
لا يوجد لديه مشروع سياسي معلن مدعم بقوه
على على الارض وراه انا في فتره من زمن
انه يستطيع استماله حركه فتح الى جانبي
هذا الرهان فشل ولكن في المقابل ايضا
فانها حركه فتح استخدمت وجوده واختبات
وراء فياض من اجل الحصول على المال طيله
الفتره الماضيه وهو محق اي فياض بان يتهم
حركه فتح بانها هي التي لعبت الدوري
الرئيسي في تعيين الوزراء الحاليين ولكنها
تتنصل من السياسه هنا اقول شيئا حركه فتح
لا يمكنها الا تنتظر اقامه او استقاله
فياض هي تستطيع ان تدفع بوزراءها نحو
الاستقاله من الحكومه لكي تنهار ومعهم
ايضا ثلاثه وزراء يمثلون الثلاثه فصائل
حليفه لحركه فتح ويعارضون كل يوم سياسه
صياد بل وشاركوا في الاحتجاجات على الارض
واعدى هذه الفصائل اصدر بيانا صحفيا قبل
ايام طالب الرئيس باقاله رياض وتشكيل
الحكومه اخرى
اليه في الحاله الفلسطينيه مؤسرت اليه سيد
شاهين وهنا اسال السيد رغمه ما اشرت اليه
من ان
رئيس الوزراء سلام فياض كان معترض على
التوجه الى عضويه كامله في في الامم
المتحده عندما فشلت المسائل في مجلس الامن
اعترض على التوجه الى الجمعيه العامه
ويعترض حتى على الدخول في مواجهات
دبلوماسيه مع اسرائيل في بعض المحافل
الدوليه هل يمكن ان يكون الخلاف بين
الرئيس عباس وسلام فياض بهذه الخطوره في
مسائل بالغه الحساسيه للملف الفلسطيني
سيدراغمه
لا اعتقد ذلك اولا الموضوع الملف السياسي
هو في منظمه التحرير وليس في السلطه
الرئيس هو رئيس منظمه التحرير وهو يعقد
اجتماع للقياده الفلسطينيه وهم يقررون
خطواتهم السياسيه في مساله النقاش بشان
التوجه الى اللون المتحده كان هنالك اصوات
عديده داخل المؤسسه الفلسطينيه التي تعارض
التوجه الى الجمعيه الى مجلس الامن وتفضل
التوجه الى الجمعيه في المرحله الاولى كان
هنالك نقاش محدود لكن الرئيس حسم هذا
النقاش وذهب الى الامم المتحده فياض كان
له اجتهاد تماما مثل الكثير من اعضاء
اللجنه التنفيذيه واللجنه المركزيه لكنه
لم يشكل عقبه ولم يحدث خلافا بين الرجلين
الخلاف حدث بينهما فقط على الصلاحيات
رئيس الوزراء يرى بان الرئيس يتدخل في
الحكومه وهنالك وزراء اصلا لا يقدمون
تقاريرهم الى الحكومه هم يعملون مع الرئيس
ويقدمون تقاريرهم الى الرئيس وهذا يزعج
رئيس الحكومه وبالتالي
اتفجرت المشكله اخ يرا في وزير المال الذي
استقال وقدم استقالته الى رئيس الحكومه
قبلها رئيس الحكومه لكن الرئيس رفضها
واعاده في اليوم التالي وهنا شعر
رئيس الحكومه بان هنالك تعدي على صلاحياته
وكان هنالك وسطاء وحاولوا البحث عن صيغ حل
وسط لكن يبدو ان الخلافات التي تراكمت بين
الرجلين الشريكين خلال السنوات
الست الماضيه وصلت الى طريق مسدود وكان
لابد من الافتراق الشراكه بينهما كانت على
اساس
راسين الان
السلطه لا يوجد لها راسين
الرئيس يكون يريد ان يكون
بغض النظر بغض النظر
عن الاسباب المتعلقه بهذا الخلاف بين
الرئيس محمود عباس ورئيس وزرائه نريد ان
نعرف بعد الفاصل العوامل التي سيكون لها
القول الفصل للحسم في هذا الموضوع سواء
لجهه ابقاء فياض او لجهه رحيل سنعود بعد
فاصل نرجو ان تبقوا معنا
انا بكم من جديد نزلتم معنا في هذه الحلقه
التي نناقش فيها ابعاد وخلفيات الجدل بشان
استقاله رئيس الوزراء الفلسطيني سلام فياض
سيد خليل شاهين هناك حديث الان عن ضغوطات
تتعرض لها السلطه ويتعرض لها عباس وسلام
فياض ضغوطات امريكيه اسرائيليه اوروبيه
لعدم الحسم في هذه الاستقاله والابقاء على
السيد فياض هل يمكن ان تكلل بالنجاح
ولكن هناك ايضا يعني امكانيه وهو سيناريو
المرجح هو ان يطلب من فياض الاستمرار في
منصبه او ان يقبل استقالته ويطلب منه ان
يشكل او ان يبقى في الحكومه كحكومه تسيير
اعمال الى حين ولكن اذا قسمنا الضغوط الى
ضغوط خارجيه وضغوط داخليه سيد رغبه
الخارجيه مثلما اشترن قبل قليل الامريكيه
اسرائيليه اوروبيه الداخليه حركه فتح
والراي العام الفلسطيني الذي يشتكي من
ارتفاع الاسعار ومن مسائل اخرى حياتيه
معيشيه برايك اي العاملين سيكون الاكثر
تاثيرا في قرار الرئيس محمود عباس
واضح ان لا يوجد تاثير للعاملين الرئيس
محمود عباس اتخذ قراره وايضا الدكتور سلام
فياض اتخذ قراره انا اعمل مراسل اخباري
ومعلوماتي ان الرجلين متمسكان في موقفيهما
لا يوجد اي تغيير على الموقفين
الدكتور سلام فياض لا يريد ان يكون تابعا
في المؤسسه يريد ان يكون له خياره وشخصيته
واستقلاليته والرئيس محمود عباس يريد ان
يضع الامور يوحد المؤسسه كلها تحت قيادته
لذلك واضح ان لا يوجد مخرج الوسطات
المحليه والوساطات الدوليه اخفقت في جسر
الهوى بين الرجلين هنالك خلاف شخصي واضح
وبالتالي من الصعب التعايش معه على الارجح
ان استقاله الدكتور فياض ستكون نافذه في
الساعات القليله القادمه ولكن سيد رغم اذا
ما استندنا الى مقالته رويترز من ان
الدبلوماسي
دبلوماسي غربي طلب من القياده الفلسطينيه
ان تؤجل البث لمده شهرين هل التاجيل ايضا
وارد
انا استبعد هذا التاجيل اولا لان الدكتور
فياض قدم استقالته وهي ليست المره الاولى
التي يقدم فيها استقالته الرجل له خياراته
السياسيه يعني غير متمسك في المنصب لان
المنصب ياخذ منه في هذه المرحله ولا يعطيه
وجود اي شخص في رئاسه الحكومه الفلسطينيه
في هذه المرحله ياخذ منه ولا يعطيه لان
السلطه تعاني من ازمه ماليه ومن ازمه
اقتصاديه ومن ازمه سياسيه وبالتالي
اي رئيس حكومه سيواجه مشكلات متراكمه منذ
عقود وهنالك شح في التمويل الدولي هنالك
مشكلات معقده وبالتالي لا يوجد ما يدفع
سلام فياض الى البقاء في الحكم ولكن ما
يمكن ان يدفع الرئيس محمود عباس وهنا اسال
السيد خليل شاهين ما يمكن ان يدفع الرئيس
محمود عباس
للحسم في هذا الموضوع ان في مرات سابقه
الرئيس عباس اثبت انه لا يخضع للضغوط
ودليل
التوجه الى الجمعيه العامه رغم كل الضغوط
الدوليه وحتى العربيه لثني عن الذهاب في
موضوع سلام فياض برايك هل يمكن ان يتصرف
بنفس التصرف السابق
يعني هذه المره الامر مختلف هذه المره
الطرف الاخر وهو فياض لا يريد ان يبقى في
هذا المنصب حتى يوم امس معلوماتي تشير لان
فياض كان يؤكد انه سيقول للرئيس بانه لن
يبقى يوما واحدا اضافيا في منصبه بمعنى
اخر هو لا يريد البقاء يعني تغييرا جذري
جذريا في معادله العلاقه ما بين الرئيس
ورئيس الوزراء وهذا امر غير وارد بالنسبه
للرئيس عباس في هذه المهره المرحله نحن
الان في مرحله البحث عن المخارج في مرحله
ما بعد وجود سلام فياض في رئاسه الحكومه
ما هو المخرج المناسب اعتقد ان الرئيس
ربما يكون الان منخرط في البحث عن مخرج
ملائم اي ان تكون هناك تشكيله حكوميه اما
بالتوافق مع حركه حماس لرئاسه الرئيس اما
الاضطراب بتشكيل حكومه برئاسه شخصيه
مستقله ولكن مقبوله من الاطراف
الدوليه اما تشكيل يعني حكومه مقلثه مقلصه
من المستقلين برئاسه الرئيس نفسه واعتقد
ان هذه الامكانيه وارده اذا نحن علينا ان
عده ايام لنرى ما هو القرار الذي سيتخذه
الرئيس عباس في مرحله ما بعد فياض هذه
المرحله انتهت واصبحت ورانا واعتقد ان
الفياض الان ربما يفكر في المشروع السياسي
الذي سوف يقدم عليه بشكل مستقل ومن خارج
الحكم خلال المرحله المقبله ولكن سيد
شاهين هذا لا يجعل الرئيس عباس في في مازق
صح التعبير على اساس ان ليس فقط واشنطن
واسرائيل والدول الاوروبيه وربما حتى
الدول العربيه تريد ابقاء سلام فياض وهو
لا يريد البقاء مقابل ايضا هيئات دوليه
البنك الدولي صندوق النقد الدول المانحه
بشكل ادق هذه الاطراف كلها جميعا لا
تستطيع ان تلعب دور مؤثر في هذا الاتجاه
او ذاك
الاتحاد الاوروبي موقفه واضح وخصوصا بعد
التوافق ما بين فتح وحماس على تشكيل حكومه
توافقيه برئاسه الرئيس الاشارات القادمه
من الاتحاد الاوروبي تؤكد ان انه سيواصل
تقديم الدعم للحكومه اذا كانت برئاسه
الرئيس وتضم شخصيات مستقله كما ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي لا يعارض من حيث الجوهر وجود
شخصيه مستقله اخرى في رئاسه الحكومه طالما
انها ملتزمه ببرنامج الرئيس عباس لذلك انا
اعتقد ان المشكله قد تكون مع اسرائيل بشكل
رئيسي وكذلك مع الولايات المتحده ولكن
دعنا هنا نتذكر ان احد اسباب الضعف
والكشاف حكومه فياض هو اقدام اسرائيل على
خطوات
بمنع تحويل الاموال خلال الفتره الماضيه
للحكومه وكذلك وقت تحويل المساعدات
الامريكيه لهذه الحكومه اي انا اسرائيل
والولايات المتحده شركتين في اضعاف فياض
واصاله الى هذه المحطه وهذا الامر قد
يتكرر مع اي رئيس وزراء قادم سيد درغمه
باختصار شديد في نهايه البرنامج
تعتقد ان هذا الموضوع سيحسم في غضون هذا
الاسبوع
على الارجح انه سيحسم يوم غدا وبالنسبه
للمجتمع الدولي الحقيقه ان المؤسسات
الدوليه الدولي المانحه ابدت في تقاريرها
السابقه ارتياحا للتعامل مع الدكتور سلام
فياض من الناحيه المهنيه وليس من الناحيه
السياسيه من الناحيه السياسيه كل المؤسسه
السياسيه الفلسطينيه موحده في خياراتها
السياسيه كل السلطه الفلسطينيه قريبه من
الغرب وهي منفتحه على الغرب وهي ضمن
المنظومه الغربيه فبالتالي لا يوجد تمايز
بينهما في هذا الجانب شكرا جزيلا لك سيد
محمد رغم الصحفي والمحلل السياسي
الفلسطيني كنت معنا من رام الله ومن رام
الله ايضا السيد خليل شاهين مدير البحوث
في مركز مسارات لابحاث السياسات والدراسات
الاستراتيجيه بهذا نكون قد وصلنا الى
نهايه هذه الحلقه دمتم في رعايه الله والى